I am a nutritional pharmacist I'm a
registered pharmacist but I always felt
like uh prescription drugs are toxic
versions of what nutrients are and I
always felt like why are we messing
around with the toxic versions with the
synthetic versions the artificial
versions of what um of what the Divine
force or what nature uses As Natural
medicines so when we have health
challenges often times there are
nutritional deficien deficiencies behind
those health challenges of course makes
sense considering the fact that the
standard American diet and processed
food and marketing and eating for
emotional reasons and eating for cost
reasons aside from along with soil
deficiencies and and food processing
issues um have conspired to make the
average American deficient in nutrients
so I was felt like why aren't we just
replacing those nutrients and why aren't
we just using nutrients as for their
medicinal value as in in essence natural
medicines are God's medicine and so I've
started incorporating nutrition
supplements to my practice back in the
1980s and sure enough as you would
expect uh people got better and not only
do they get better but even when they
were on prescription drugs their
prescription drugs worked better so much
so that they could uh they could uh
reduce their dose of their medications
sometimes completely eliminating their
medications for example using B vitamins
or magnesium for hypertension or using
magnesium for cardiovascular health
issues or using zinc for skin health
issues or using uh selenium and uh
sulfur and iodine for thyroid health
issues what we found is is that people
get better they could reduce their dose
of drugs or they could U or they could
completely eliminate their drugs as it
turns out chronic health conditions are
rooted more often than not in in uh porn
nutrition as well as in digestive health
issues that compromise the absorption of
nutrients traditional Health Care in my
opinion overlooks the power of nutrition
overlooks the power of food as well as
the power of nutritional supplements for
their healing for uh healing properties
healing potential nutrition can be used
by today's modern Health Care profal not
only to achieve their health care goals
and their patients healthare goals but
also as a way to generate income and as
a pharmacist I can tell you that our
specialty our the specialty or the the
job of a pharmacist is not necessarily
to dispense pharmaceutical but to
dispense medical
interventions that can be used to heal
the body and those Medical interventions
can be nutrition and it's not just
pharmacists who can leverage this
chiropractors acupuncturists Physicians
dentists podiatrists anybody who's
dealing with patients who are who have
uh health challenges that they have to
address can Leverage The Power of
nutrition to help their patients get
healthy as well as to help their bottom
line in their business so we're going to
do a webinar root cause solutions for
healthier lives we're going to teach
healthc Care Professionals how to use
nutritional supplements in their
business to cover the fundamental
nutritional deficiency roots of chronic
disease to develop personalized
nutrition plans to empower their
patients to make inform for food choices
and ultimately to elevate your practice
to new heights you will learn how to
have improved how to improve patient
outcomes how to increase patient patient
satisfaction how to expand practice
opportunities I'm pharmacist Benjamin
iugs from truth skin Health Products and
youngevity inviting you to attend our
webinar root cause solutions for
healthier lives you're not going to want
to miss this opportunity to transform
your practice register now